the last is ficklin that's f like and
frank i-c-k-l-i-n
i'm a lieutenant with the las vegas
metropolitan police department traffic
bureau
and the preliminary information we have
from today's their tonight's incident
is at approximately 6 40 this evening
eight-year-old child was riding his
bicycle
through the parking lot of his apartment
complex at the same time
a truck was driving through one of the
driveways or the causeways of the
apartment complex
and making a gentle left turn
around along a curve and
it from what it appears what happened
was
the child's bike collided with the
right side of the truck as he was making
a left turn
and the child went down medical
responded transported the child
to sunrise hospital but unfortunately
the child did not survive
the collision with the truck the driver
of the truck
remained on scene and has been
cooperative with the investigation
and at this time we do not believe that
either
intoxication or uh speed
is a factor in this collision it's just
unfortunate incident that happened today
and in a parking lot
you were saying earlier this is just
very rare for something like this to
happen in a parking lot like this right
it's very where you know usually there's
other circumstances that are involved
uh you know oftentimes when we deal with
collisions
or we hear of incidents like this
there's there's a speed factor or other
things involved that
uh we we're just not seeing that under
these circumstances
so was the child going really fast on
his bicycle
uh we're still trying to determine uh
exactly what happened and how that
happened
but that's what our fatal team is
is they've been here for the last hour
working on that investigation and
uh they're trying to figure out exactly
how it happened and why
so is it safe to say this just seems
like a very unfortunate circumstance
a very unfortunate circumstance and
um but we you something to take away
from this for everybody is
uh you know just be mindful of what
you're doing and when you're doing it
uh you know we'll be on the streets and
on the roadways and you'll see people on
their phones and
and uh doing other things and not really
focusing on
the driving that they're doing and and
uh you know so
whether you're on the roadway whether
you're in a parking lot for an
apartment complex we ask that you pay
attention to what you're doing at that
time
when you're behind the wheel that's not
the time to be multitasking
that's the time to be focusing on what
you're doing because
you're in this vehicle that weighs a few
thousand pounds and
when it comes up against a human that
is far less in weight uh the outcomes of
that
the outcomes that come with those
collisions don't usually go very well
for the
for the human so uh please be mindful of
what you're doing when you're doing it
uh be careful on the roadways be careful
in parking lots
and uh almost anticipate that
uh something's gonna happen around you
and uh
and that way we can all take care of
each other real quick um
a lot of kids are getting out of school
right now is this something that people
need to be aware of over the next few
months
uh well anytime anytime that our
children are out
playing it's always good to you know
have some supervision on the children
especially when they're out and about
and
oftentimes that can be tough kids can
have kids have a lot more energy than we
do as adults
and they can often go places much faster
than we can and get and cover distances
much
uh much faster than we can but uh
it's uh just incidences like this
make you contemplate on circumstances
and
you know we hope that people take this
as an opportunity to reflect on
you know if if i'm in these
circumstances where i see these
circumstances
uh what can be done differently how's
the family doing
uh the family right now is at the
hospital and so we have not
uh we have not i have not had contact
with the family
um but i can tell you that the uh the
driver of the vehicle
um he's he's very shocking up
about the he's shaken up about the
incident and he and his family are here
and
uh and uh trying to deal with it the
best they can so you mentioned
you know speeding impairment not factors
at this time
not at this time distracted driving a
factor that you're looking at at this
time
it can be um but unless
you know unless we have witnesses saying
this person was on their phone
um unless we have other information to
tell us that's the direction we need to
look
um but it's it would be tough to make
that determination at that time
and the driver wouldn't be facing any
charges at this time
at this moment with the way the
investigation goes
we'll have to see how the investigation
fully turns out
um but uh you know either way
it's just it's bad circumstances all the
way around
and last question for you um from me you
know when it comes to children
you guys are seasoned professionals
seasoned officers but when there's a
situation with a child it hits
differently
how is that going for you and your other
officers at this moment
you know for as seasoned as an officer
as you can be
you know dealing with dealing with
issues or dealing with crimes or dealing
with circumstances that involve children
is always tough especially when the
majority of us have our own children
and you can't help but think you know
this child's the same age as mine or
this child the same age as my nephew
and so it's really tough uh fortunately
our department
has an employee assistance program that
we have uh assets and we have um
uh we have assistance that's available
to us
uh for the times that we um because we
are human
um that we experience those things be it
an incident like this
be it a traumatic event
at any other incidence where when it
affects us emotionally
that we're able to get the help and the
guidance and the assistance that we need
and so we're fortunate as a department
that we have those resources available
to us
thank you guys